April first we began our journey that is
at the border of Arizona and Mexico and
I promise you we did not plant that flag
there we just rolled up in real life
it's kind of photogenic we'll take a
picture next flag so we started our
journey and we had a few hiccups kind of
day to our was to charge the maps and I
I would I didn't didn't get lost like I
always knew where I was but the
landscape wasn't exactly what I had
intended it to be like so you were
planning on like a 22-mile day and it
ended up being 40 and we finally got
into camp at like 3 o'clock in the
morning that guy was grumpy that's
understandable
and this is some of the training that we
were going through it's just absolutely
beautiful we were coming down a hill
this is all night a number 4 this is the
director this is Phil Baraboo this guy's
an amazing cameraman if you ever need to
do a film project he is your dude
but Phil it's not a horseman in fact
he'd only ridden a horse like once
higher to the journey he's pretty handy
now but on day number 4 he was tired
which is understandable he stood like 40
mile forced march and he's gone downhill
no horse is in front of him and he's not
paying attention he just walks in to
this horse and the horse just reaches
back and just tagging right in the thigh
like I mean if he took a sack of
potatoes and just dropped it but it
actually didn't sound like that at all
um but it sounded bad and we thought
that his leg was broken because of the
sounds that he made
uh how I wish I had that audio um but uh
ruin up there and you know took his
pants off he had this massive bruise
that was in the perfect shape of a
horseshoe I mean it was it was really
not he was a size one shoe um which was
cool because for the rest of the journey
we watched this big blood bubble go all
the way down its leg and out his toe it
was really cool we should have a time
lapse on it that'd be amazing um but
yeah and then my father-in-law whose
doctor he gave us all these drugs before
we left like hard if you get in buying
you know use this for this and this for
that and we're in a hurry and we're in a
bond so I'm just like filly TAS like
keep that and I think we ended up
accidentally giving him some muscle
relaxers we put him back on the horse
and he's like sure the next three hours
and we we limped out of there and he
rode but he was in bad shape he had to
go to the hospital but he was fine ah
but it was it was tough because then
whenever the cameraman weren't there we
had to be the cameraman and sometimes
our stuff wasn't as in focuses there's
this guy I love this man so much his
name is Val Geisler and he stopped
everything that he was doing in life you
74 and said I'm gonna take two months
and go help you boys and twos are road
crews Arizona and old-time horse trainer
has adopted dozens of mustangs and
helped us start the journey and parted
all of this this cowboy wisdom that he's
just a dying breed an amazing human
being then famer got dysentery after you
get kicked in the head by horse he got
over that too
um moving on we got to the Grand Canyon
we went down South Rim crossed over the
bridge down at the bottom the horses
were like I don't know about this she
had to go through a cave and then onto a
bridge and then on this little tiny goat
path but they did fantastic these horses
after about the first couple weeks and
they they if you're always going on and
they were excellent excellent ponies and
maybe that's possibly the reason why
Thamer thought it was a good idea to get
a donkey but I think another thing is
you know people think of the wild horse
issue is like a wild horse issue but you
know the burros are really important and
you wanted a burro so happy finally a
little fun when I dropped off the three
horses a couple weeks ago famer asked me
about the burros and if I had a burro to
bring him and I just happened to have
one oh that's perfect
take that back Brandon what donkey
whisper the donkey I definitely adds a
little flavor to our outfit little some
the board flavor that's pretty good then
yes you have no idea what she just got
herself in
[Music]
now I like donkeys but aliens gonna do
fleet disastrous I just don't think doc
he can do 20 miles a day know the rough
terrain keeping up with full-size horses
he's just big enough I give the donkey a
couple weeks
[Music]
maybe you'll just follow along
peacefully
maybe we'll be mad as a donkey on donkey
[Music]
[Music]
and the donkey proceeded to follow us
all the way to Canada yeah I wish I was
Jeb broader I love that donkey um it's
kind of funny like I uh I keep she stays
at Tom Weber's house in Texas right I
have my horses right now we have these
seven Mustangs and this donkey and
everywhere the donkey goes there's like
seven Pig Mustangs that follow her
around and single-file line
it's like Queen Leader she was nice to
have around you know horses they kind of
do their own little horse neighing but
donkeys they really like people and
there was a lot of times we would just
be hanging out and donkey would just
come in and like give us her she loved
you to hear scratch her ass to you just
be hitting there like also there's a
donkey butt in your face but there were
some some downfalls of having donkey she
um would eat all of our stuff like if
you could if you kept a granola bar or
something in your pocket she would like
go and find it should we eat it and we
kept losing our spoons we we met this
this people this this family and their
their professional spoon makers and make
wooden spoons they gave us some of these
wooden spoons and you know whenever
you're in the back country and something
goes missing there's like four people
and you're a certain that it wasn't you
you're like somebody has my stuff or
like it's not my fault somebody else did
it like who has taken my spoon and one
day and there's like animosity in the
group under like wondering where the
spoons are at we're like eating with our
hands so we got down to one spin and I
looked over at donkey one day and she
does this spoon in her mouth just going
all
look like Bugs Bunny the spoons just
getting smaller and smaller like
splinters flying everywhere it's really
incredible she ate her spoon but we
forgave her I love that donkey but we uh
we tried not to take ourselves too
seriously big fake fan of Harry Potter
but unlike most people I wouldn't really
consider myself a Gryffindor there my no
more mother give you something I think
if I had
special powers that would Crowley speak
Parseltongue
he was figured that would be good
opportunity to scare masters
a masters masters semester Oh getting
back one day um but yeah it was
incredible it was just an amazing thing
to do and not not throwing snakes on
each other but like the journey as a
whole and it was it was neat because
whenever you do a big expedition like
that it becomes kind of a lifestyle like
whenever you go on a backpacking trip or
a weekend vacation or something which
you know I'm all for it I love doing
that but it's different because you're
like leaving this lifestyle and doing a
vacation it fits for like a week or two
weeks or three days or whatever then you
come back but whenever you're out there
for five months it stops becoming a
vacation and it becomes this lifestyle
and it was really neat to kind of
compare that lifestyle to what it was
before hand and then what it is now and
some of the things that I really really
enjoyed about that trip you know beyond
the scenery and beyond all that was the
camaraderie you know whenever you're you
don't have the ability to look at your
email or your Instagram or your cell
phone or anything and you're forced to
sit and talk with other people for hours
that's something that I don't really
have happen a lot you know since this
trip and I really enjoyed that sense of
friendship and of closeness and of
disconnection I also really enjoyed just
like the very physical nature of the
decisions you know it wasn't you know am
I going to do this digital project or
that digital project or try to push this
product or whatever it was am I going to
go split wood or am I gonna clean dishes
are we going to go left or we're going
to go right
was a very physical existential kind of
lifestyle that that I really enjoyed and
it's an experience that I'm really glad
that I have so I always encourage people
to ride horses from Mexico to Canada and
I mean just some of the country that we
saw this photo here was taken by Cory
Richards who's an SEO photographer
absolutely awesome guy mazie
photographer and just kind of a piece of
public land this is the loss at plateau
this isn't a wilderness it's not a
national monument it's not a national
park it's not like this iconic place
that people think of going to but it's
incredible I mean it's stunning it's
aspen trees for as far as you can look
vistas that are you know world-class and
it's it's it's ours it's public land and
we have an amazing amount of it we're so
fortunate to have it I don't know if I'm
ever gonna look cooler in my life than I
do right there so it takes a NatGeo
photographer to make me look cool and
this was in Yellowstone and that's great
horse and frisky at semi and that is
stumbles and that's dinosaur off to the
right kind of looks like a dinosaur this
is a Glacier National Park um definitely
one of the finest views of the entire
journey and this was crossing the
Gallatin River in Montana it's kind of a
hairy spot but by point time our ponies
rockstars and one more in Glacier but it
was it is impossible to not be just
completely overwhelmed by the landscapes
that we went to and and went through and
alright here's here's just a just a
piece of
some of the stuff that was all
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
American West is pretty amazing I wasn't
very profound I tried to thinking some
really profound to say right there I
left the video speak for itself
um but man I would've turned yet I
really kind of want to do it again and
then on September 6 of 2013 we got to
the Canadian border
and we completed our trip at Glacier
National Park it's kind of give you guys
a sense of what it takes to create a
massive production like this you know
our producer a production assistant
assistant editor Paul Quigley some of
the students from Montana State
University fill in the Hat and then
Corey were the two cinematographers so
you know it takes a big team to put a
production like this together and the
two cinematographers are kind of the
humble ones in the trip you know they
did the entire journey and they filmed
it all and you know they weren't in it
but it wouldn't have happened without
him but just just amazing amazing guys
and they were you know as much of the
team as anybody else
there's surprise in the movie you can
have to watch movie to find out about
the ending but we we finished the trip
then it was it was it was weird because
like it was it was time to end but at
the same time you know we kind of wanted
it to continue but you know it was
becoming fall is about to get winter it
was it was time to finish but the horses
they just did such a good job
and whenever we finished I decided to
try to think of a way to kind of give
back to the horses because you know they
took us all the way from Mexico to
Canada and didn't really know how and
then I learned about this event that
they do in Fort Worth with the Mustang
heritage found
station where they have these training
competitions with the purpose of getting
these wild horses adopted and finding
homes for them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our trip probably would have been
possible with del fuste here to build it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so I gave away I gave away my Mustang
Luke he's here with my fishing horse
like you don't just give away your
fishing horse um somebody asked me today
with my favorite fly-fishing Firewise I
told him a horsefly but anyways we gave
we gave Luke way and with that money
what they do is they they pay horse
trainers to train these horses to make
more adoptable to other people then they
launched a veteran's program with it and
then a few months after I auctioned him
off guy bought him a guy named Tom
O'Brien Tulsa Oklahoma he called me out
of the blue and said you know Ben I
bought that horse because I wanted to
make a donation to the Mustang Heritage
Foundation and we're not riding him and
I'd like for you to have him back uh
will you take this horse back because
you know I'd done a lot with him and
Hughes didn't really want to give him up
I was kind of having regrets about
giving away so whenever you offered that
and I was like you know are you sure
number one that's huge
it's like one of the kind of things
anybody has ever done for me whenever
you say yes it's like yeah of course I
want my horse back he's awesome horse my
fishing buddy uh and I'm pretty certain
I don't know this but I have put on the
spot but um I think that my wife said
yes because of my horse
and I really don't blame her um so we
got married
not too long after I'm branded and she
put up with that I was gonna put a
ringer on her and this is our family da
yeah pretty proud of my family that
tough Luke violent or violet and a
dinosaur ah they're my boys Natali got a
read that's the book that I wrote it's
horse grade reading level he really
likes the pictures and one of the
biggest honors that I had well yes with
unbranded it did really well the movie
turned out a lot better than we had
expected it to which is a testament to
the filmmaking team and we ended up
taking it to different film festivals
and it got picked up we got put on
Netflix so a lot of people got to see it
and we were able to do a theatrical run
um probably showed like 500 theaters in
the u.s. like it did really well it got
a lot of eyeballs on the film and and to
know that these forces were there for
adoption we had a lot of horses adopted
which I'm very proud of and one of the
biggest honors is after the release of
unbranded I was nominated to sit on a
volunteer panel the wild horse and burro
advisory board which is a group of
volunteers that meet to advise the BLM
on how to manage their wild horse
populations and the role that that I was
nominated to sit on was wildlife
management which is a dream come true
because as a wildlife biologist you know
I was now able to represent the
interests of wildlife on 31.2
in acres of public lands in the American
West which is really nice but it's also
a difficult subject because there's a
lot of horses it's a political topic
that involves horses and wildlife and
ecology and the ranching industry and
public private land mixture but this is
kind of where the wild horses exists in
the West it's that these are actually
heard areas they're actually a little
bit smaller than herd management areas
where they actually exist but you can
see mainly in ten western states and
they're still rounded up horses and
they're still putting them in pins and
it's just a completely broken system
that everybody will agree with you that
the wild horse and burro situation is a
complete wreck you know there's three
times the amount of horses on the range
that it's the target population which is
controversial to itself and then you
know almost 50,000 of them sitting in
feedlots and sitting on lease pasture
it's insanely expensive and it's just
ignited this huge controversy in the
West and as we were touring unbranded
we showed it at Telluride mount film and
I met this amazing woman named TJ Holmes
who decided to do something about it in
the area that she could I mean she told
me about it I was like I want to make a
movie on this dinging that was the cue
for the movie I missed it all right but
before I do show that before I show that
film
sorry before I show that film I do want
to talk about one thing which is we have
over a million livestock on public lands
in the American West we have 75 thousand
wild horses and burros and bison the
undeniably native large herbivore is
virtually non-existent on our public
lands with the exception of Yellowstone
National Park in like two or three other
places and I always thought like that is
crazy
you know we've exterminated the Bison
their populations are now a lot higher
than they were 120 years ago but I think
it would be pretty cool cease of bison
reintroductions into our public lands
uh-huh um let's see what happens but
this is a picture of me and all that
grass that you see is all cheatgrass
it's an invasive annual and it is not
native and has taken over somewhere
around 50 million acres of the American
West to put that into perspective that's
about 20 Yellowstone national parks it's
a massive massive issue and it can be
caused by over grazing of cattle horses
of wildlife and it just kind of shows
the importance of management on you know
in this area there's like federal or
state there's private and it kind of
shows the importance of different
agencies working together to try to
prevent a massive invasive species
monocultures from popping up because it
threatens biodiversity threatens teeny
species it's just not a good situation
and now here's the film that I was
talking about five minutes you
I'm TJ and I document that Mustangs a
spring crude Basin
I've been doing that for about nine
years now I volunteer for BLM eidart
with the pzp fertility control vaccine
to try to slow the population growth in
Spring Creek Basin but I'll stop it
so we can at least lengthen the interval
between roundups that's amazing thing
that that little thing right there
is gonna prevent her from having a fall
for a year which will potentially
prevent a horse from growing up being
rounded up going to a holding pen
there's that shove the rifle and then
that merde jobs it's like a school of
fish
[Music]
the whole band is tuned into each other
so when she darts they all go like you
could see what these guys they didn't go
very far
Spring Creek Basin is almost 22,000
acres but it wouldn't matter if we were
two hundred and twenty thousand acres
make all the theory behind it is still
the same you know you've got to have the
resource to enable the horses and the
other wildlife to live here and if you
don't have that you don't have a healthy
wad horse herd you don't have a healthy
elk herd you don't have a healthy deer
herd a pronghorn herd it's the same type
of conservation philosophy for us to
make the pzp program work here we
couldn't do it without volunteers like
TJ it's a smaller herd area we have a
smaller number of horses what works here
for us does not necessarily work exactly
the same from her Tara to her area can
it be used everywhere maybe not
key word maybe I don't know does the
alum know my goal really is to manage on
the range manage them where they're
found in the wild in an ideal situation
I'd like to see BLM adopt more
partnership models use volunteers to
help document help dart with PGP to
lower the birth rate of the horses on
their ranges to the point where we can
equal the horses coming off the range
with with the adoption demand I'm making
sure that every Muir has the chance to
contribute for genetics here where our
2016 we haven't had a roundup won't need
one for at least another couple of years
because of the success of PGP in Spring
Creek Basin that has been the has been
my life in a nutshell but it's a pretty
good thing because you can look back on
these last nine years and say you know
what
I made a difference isn't that heard of
my heart and that's why I do what I do
that's pretty cool what she's doing and
what she says at the end I think you
know just really strikes home it's like
if we can get if we can use fertility
control so the population growth to
where the amount that do need to be
removed equals the adoption demand then
we can stop putting them in feedlots
which everybody wants in my opinion and
some people don't like me because of
this I don't believe that we're going to
get to that situation without some type
of lethal culling I hopefully I'm proven
wrong but it's a serious topic
you know you'll definitely see it next
in the next few years popping up because
it's it's only a growing issue
[Music]
you